Ці будинки на околиці Золотого спорожніли за 5 років війни.
Місцеві мешканці залишили свої квартири через постійні обстріли.
До передових позицій української армії
звідси рукою подати, як і до окопів сепаратистів.
До лінії фронту, яку дипломатичною мовою називають
то лінією зіткнення, то, навпаки, розмежування,
прямуємо новісінькою траншеєю.
Вирили її зовсім нещодавно: глина ще геть свіжа.
Бійці розбудовують укріплення, готуються до зими.
Військові, які зазвичай неохоче говорять на камеру про політику,
зараз не приховують: від анонсованого розведення сил
вони зовсім не в захваті.
Сепаратистам не довіряють. Бояться, що ті
не відійдуть, а займуть укріплення, які залишить українська армія.
- Я б не відводив. Якщо залишити селище,
тут буде те ж саме, що було до того, як зайшла українська армія.
Можливе беззаконня, мародерство, як це було в 2014-му році.
- Я вважаю, це не та ситуація, коли можна сказати,
що згори видніше.
Саме звідси видніше.
Саме от йому - солдату - йому видніше.
Ризик? Що ми розійшлися, стали на визначені рубежі,
створили демілітаризовану зону, але супротивник
не дотримався цього. Не захотів.
І він таким чином просунувся далі.
Активні бойові дії на фронті біля Золотого зараз не ведуться,
але й перемир’я немає. Стріляють навіть посеред білого дня.
Ось і зараз: раптом нашу розмову переривають постріли.
- Що це було?
- Це "приліт". Дуже схоже на РПГ.
Он, бачите.
Попри постійну небезпеку, зовсім поруч від лінії вогню
все ще живуть люди.
У Золотому-4, одній з п’яти частин міста Золоте,
залишилося близько 500 мирних мешканців.
Місцева волонтерка Марина Данилкіна
знайомить нас зі своїми сусідами - Олександром і Тетяною.
Вони пенсіонери, як і більшість тутешніх.
Олександр майже 30 років пропрацював на шахті.
Подружжя вже встигло відремонтувати будинок,
пошкоджений під час обстрілів на початку війни,
але спогади про той період закарбувалися назавжди.
- Тут уламками побило. Влучило в антену.
Стіну пробило уламками.
- Он туди влучив снаряд, потім он тут влучив снаряд.
А ми сиділи надворі. Якби не кухня, нас би вже не було давно.
- А стріляв хто?
- З окупованої території.
Сепаратисти. З Первомайська.
- Свої ж по своїх не будуть стріляти…
Сьогодні в селищі значно спокійніше, ніж на початку війни.
Утім, стрілянину тут усе одно можна почути ледь не щоночі,
тож вікна залишаються заклеєні скотчем,
щоб не поранило уламками скла, якщо шибки
раптом виб’є вибуховою хвилею від чергового "прильоту".
Пенсіонери Олександр і Тетяна покладають великі сподівання
на анонсоване розведення військ. Натомість
їхня сусідка, волонтерка Марина Данилкіна,
бачить у цьому лише небезпеку.
- Ми вважаємо, що розведення - це для того,
щоб не було таких важких обстрілів.
Починають гатити одне по одному,
а страждають мирні мешканці. То хати побило,
то уламками когось вбило.
- Але коли розведуть, сюди прийдуть
оці всі війська з окупованої сторони.
- Я вважаю, що ні.
- У них своя територія є, далі вони нікуди не підуть.
- Це здача України. Тут українська територія.
Тут завжди були українські війська, і це так
повинно залишитися. Але капітуляції не повинно бути.
Всі проукраїнські, хто за Україну, тут будуть розстріляні.
Тут буде багато біди, горя і лиха.
Робити опитування перехожих у Золотому -
марна справа, адже вулиці міста порожні навіть удень.
Вимирати Золоте почало задовго до війни
через занепад вугільної промисловості.
Основні роботодавці в місті - дві старі збиткові
шахти, де робітникам місяцями не платять зарплатню.
А частину міста - селище Золоте-5 - контролюють
підтримувані Росією сепаратисти. Чи не єдине,
що побудували в Золотому за останні роки, -
пункт пропуску для перетину лінії розмежування.
Втім, своєї функції він не виконує:
до так званої "ЛНР" через нього не потрапити,
адже бойовики відмовляються відкривати КПВВ зі свого боку.
Нині пункт пропуску "Золоте" працює фактично
як звичайний блокпост. Тут контролюють людей,
які прямують із прифронтових, але підконтрольних
уряду селищ. Питаємо їх, що вони думають про розведення.
- Нам, мабуть, буде трошки складніше, тому що тут
більше машин буде їздити. А так,
якщо військ не буде, то взагалі буде класно. Будемо жити, як жили.
- Розведення? Я - "за" руками і ногами, щоб
усе це припинилося. За п’ять років так набридло -
я вам передати не можу.
- Українська армія має тут бути.
Якщо ті прийдуть, що потім будемо робити?
Якщо ми взагалі без захисту будемо?
Кажемо, що розводимо, а розводити в такому разі не треба.
Коли анонсоване розведення сил у Золотому стане реальністю,
поки що невідомо.
Попри заяви про підготовку до відводу військ
та періодичні чутки про те, що цей процес
нібито вже розпочався, конкретних дат і строків
наразі немає. Адже передумовою для розведення сил
є повна тиша на фронті. А там все ще стріляють…